you
hi everyone is cherry this is game 9
from the 2014 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Vishy
Anand going into this game Carlson has a
four and a half to three and a half lead
and Carlsen with the white pieces in
this one he opened with e4 we followed
Game seven of this match all the way up
to move ten once again revisiting the
Berlin defense with an early Queen
exchange
unlike Game seven that marathon Game
seven where it lasted six and a half
hours and 122 moves this one lasted just
about one hour after h5 this is now
White's next move this is where we have
an adjustment in game 7 we saw Bishop f4
but what's tried now is 92 looking to
reposition the knight into F 4 or even
d4 following up we have V six looking to
throw a question to the knight and that
happens rook to d1 open file
Bishop a6 the main think of the game was
right here really what exactly to do
with the knight he decides on f4 going
elsewhere such as d4 allowing the knight
exchange black can follow at c5 this is
no serious threat in fact knight c6 at
that stage would be a blunder after
Bishop to b7 Knight f5 there can follow
h4 cramping effect to the White King
side ideas of rook h5 the knight can be
kicked as well there's no issue
whatsoever for black in this position so
he tries Knight f4 and after this the
curious move bishop beasts have in the
first I believe original position this
one here to play to a6 and now return to
b7 what are some subtle ideas behind
this when questioned about this idea of
Bishop a 6 and then Bishop to b7 in the
press conference after this game Anand
simply did not want to elaborate of
course I could see why as there is still
a match going on not wanting to give
away
any details here but something that I
can share some insight that I can offer
here regarding why you would want to
play to a six and then after the night
is jumping into f4 why do you want to
maybe play back to b7 well for one
initially why would you want to play
Bishop a6 in the first place well it
could be related to wanting to gather
some more information about the Knights
next move you know is he gonna go to f4
is he going to go to d4 I'd like to gain
a little bit more insight about where
exactly he will play once he's decided
on f4 certainly there's no worry of the
bishop coming out to f4 or even g5 and
when the bishop returns one idea that is
now available for black is to meet the
move a4 with a5
so by returning to b7 you're preparing
to meet a four with a5 now why is this
maybe a big deal well if we just make a
passing move just to illustrate my point
here this a four idea and then a5 can be
quite disruptive to the black side if
the bishop moves a5 and now white gets
to open up the a file under White's
terms and this is often a very good
position for the white side here to have
this tension to know that any black move
would be very weakening to move b5 or to
leave it sitting again white at any
moment can be the one who decides when
the Queen side opens up I believe black
wants to be in a position in other words
after Bishop to beef 7 to meet this idea
of a4 with a5 shutting it down not
giving that type of option to the white
side to open up the Queen side whenever
he wants
so after Bishop b7 we have E six
position is opening up quite a bit now a
liquidated pawn center Bishop d6
pawn takes King takes Knight g5 check
King f6 Knight e4 - very tricky Knights
around the king is quite limited with
where he can go it goes here that's a
fork pretty much locked into going back
and forth here and similarly White is in
a way locked into going for this draw by
perpetual check this repetition of
position this is where the game ends
after just these 20 moves white decides
on continually giving checks to the
black King and he's not going to be so
quick and will not be so quick - getting
him between the king and the rook by
playing back here he simply keeps
stepping up whenever he's checked and
why exactly
his white going for this can that can
white not get more in this position well
if white is not careful if he's trying
to get something more well there's
simply nothing more to get it can easily
turn the worst side if you're trying for
something other than this perpetual
check at this point and it's important
to realize that much because now you're
the side who's slightly worse black now
has a perfectly secure King ideally
placed that he would have a perfectly
secure King ideally placed on a light
square very strong knight on f5 this
pawn
having a clamping effect on the g4
advance he's not going to be kicked away
and noticed the backward the slightly
backward development of the white side
there's no way you could claim an
advantage for the white side it's just
not there trying g4 to kick the knight
well now you're in trouble on the white
side black is looking for checkmating
ideas and this is simply not a good
direction to go in so this is really the
best that Y can do unfortunately you try
to press more but if there's simply
nothing more there then it's a you know
you could easily turn slightly worse if
you're not going for this draw by
perpetual check here or this three move
repetition so this one game this game
here clearly ended quietly
much much different than the other
Berlin defense game seven out of this
opening here this one lasted about one
hour it's lasted 20 moves compared with
game seven six and a half hour 120 to
move encounter not the most exciting
game clearly this one here but I think
it only adds to the tension in these
ensuing games what we can say for sure
is that this championship will take at
least a game 11 before a world champion
is decided and I believe it's likely to
even were likely to even see a game 12
and how tense that one will be well
we'll see how this turns out as it
stands right now it is five points for
Carlsen to four and we go into game 10
which is tomorrow November 21st same
time 7 a.m. Eastern Standard Time 12
o'clock p.m. GMT we'll see how things
turn out at that point so that's all for
this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you